[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
je vous souhaite mes meilleurs voeux
pour cette année 2010 neuf une nouvelle
année durant laquelle nous continuerons
à analyser les enjeux liés à l'emploi et
à la formation professionnelle tout de
suite le sommaire trouver des employés
compétents correspondant au profil
recherché
c'est parfois le parcours du combattant
endurer pour les tpe et les pme
rencontre avec deux dirigeants
d'entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines l'approchent compétences ou le
recrutement par compétence est elle une
solution face à ces difficultés nous
poserons la question à notre invité la
directrice adjointe de pôle emploi lui
en cours aurait douchy enfin retrouvez
vous rendez vous de l'emploi à noter
dans vos agendas
en fin d'émission les petites et
moyennes entreprises et les
micro-entreprises des sociétés plus
vulnérables face aux recrutements
notamment en par rapport aux grands
groupes avec des conséquences néfastes
pour le développement de ces structures
les détails dans ce reportage deux
entreprises saint-quentinoise de
secteurs d'activité différents mais une
même problématique le recrutement
experte dans la prise de vue aérienne et
caméras en mouvement l'entreprise xd
moshen a été créé en 2011 à coignières
captation de long métrage de publicité
ou d'événements sportifs
plusieurs fabrication de systèmes avec
un hélicoptère une caméra sur câble ou
encore une voiture travelling avec bras
motorisés
ce bras est entièrement télécommandé de
l'intérieur de la voiture
ici il va venir se fixer une tête
gyrostabilisée sur laquelle on va avoir
une caméra qui permettra donc de sept
caméras de filmer à très grande vitesse
puisque l'outil peut atteindre 180
km/heure de déplacement à leur actif les
jeux olympiques d'hiver de pyongyang le
tournoi des six nations où les jeux
d'asie depuis 2011 cette société réalise
entre 20 et 30% de croissance pour
dynamiser cette croissance le
recrutement est nécessaire mais
difficile je sais c'est assez dramatique
pour nous parce qu'on peut pas se
déployer
c'est à dire que on freine on n'a pas
suffisamment de monde je pense que c'est
le plus gros problème la plus grosse
conséquence elle frein c'est le frein de
développement d'une entreprise
le recrutement est si importante donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est c'est le temps
perdu on a le sentiment que c'est plus
l'entreprise qui va
recherche de l'élève qui sort de l'école
que l' inverse et on devrait être sur
sollicité aujourd'hui on est en manque
d'élèves et on est en manque aujourd'hui
de jeunes pour d'éventuels cdi après une
des difficultés qui est lié à notre
activité c'est qu'on travaille à
l'international et que c'est vrai que la
langue requises minimum c'est l'anglais
on a beaucoup de difficultés aujourd'hui
à trouver véritablement des personnes
qui savent aac ou au moins qu'ils ont ce
niveau de langue étrangère conséquences
identiques à montigny le bretonneux chez
eurostat france cette entreprise édite
le logiciel cher au space une solution
de partage des données pour leur client
une pme composé de dix salariés
on est toujours en recherche
effectivement fait papa depuis cinq ans
on est toujours en recherche de
collaborateurs chez moi même à peu
freiné par un moment l'acceptation de
certains projets ou différé parce que on
n'était pas capable de réellement les
honorer dans les temps qui nous était
demandé par les clients avec un chiffre
d'affaires de près d'un million d'euros
un groupe reconnu à l'international et
des projets développés avec des
partenaires européens
cette société reste attractive mais avec
des critères de compétences exigeants on
a des difficultés de recrutement parce
que les solutions que l'on développe ou
d'apport font appel à des à savoir faire
qui est qui et qui reste encore kemal
kemal connu qui n'est pas diffusée dans
qui n'est pas enseignée dans l'est dans
les universités ou dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs et j'accepte plus
volontiers qu'un candidat n'est pas
l'expérience de telle ou telle
discipline
il aura toujours l'occasion de
l'acquérir le savoir-être où le
potentiel
me semble être un critère important
s'appuyer sur le savoir-faire et le
savoir-être des candidats un changement
de stratégie de recrutement appelé l'
approche compétences nous accueillons au
radouci sur notre plateau bonsoir
directrice adjointe de l'agencé pôle
emploi de guyancourt alors on vient de
voir dans le sujet deux entreprises qui
ont des difficultés face pour trouver
des candidats des futurs employés déjà
une réaction par rapport à ce que vous
venez d'entendre alors par rapport aux
difficultés en recrutement des
employeurs effectivement nous sommes
conscients que des entreprises ont des
besoins qu'elles ont besoin de répondre
à ces recrutements et ses embauches
assez rapidement pour pouvoir être
compétitive et pour pouvoir continuer à
réaliser leurs activités
il y à des enjeux aussi derrière de
développement de l'entreprise par
rapport aux besoins en compétences qui
sont recherchées l'approchent
compétences quand vous me parliez tout à
l'heure en approche compétences
effectivement ça a été abordé lors du
reportage
on est sur les savoirs sur les savoir
faire et sur les savoirs être donc sur
les candidatures qui sont proposés et
qui sont recherchées
certains candidats n'ont pas certaines
compétences maintenant parle beaucoup
plus de compétences que de profils de cv
plutôt excusez moi on parle beaucoup
plus de compétences que 2 cv et donc on
va rechercher un moment donné lorsqu'il
ya un décalage entre la compétence
recherchée est derrière la compétence
que nous avons sur le marché du travail
on va essayer de mettre en adéquation et
adapter les compétences recherchées et
les compétences qui sont sur le marché
du travail
pour cela nous pouvons nous appuyer sur
des actions d'adaptation au poste de
travail se traduire concrètement qu'est
ce que c'est ce sont des préparation
opérationnelle à l'emploi par exemple ce
sont des actions de formation préalable
au recrutement qui sont mises en place
parce qu'il manque une compétence c'est
ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
lorsqu'il y avait une difficulté qui
était la langue requise
l'anglais s'est également lorsque
monsieur giraud par les amants
données d'un savoir faire qui n'était
pas enseigné au niveau des écoles donc
c'est un moment donné pouvoir donner la
chance à des candidats qui ont des
compétences qui n'ont peut-être pas
toutes les compétences mais qui ont des
compétences et pour lesquels il faut
apporter une adaptation parce qu'il ya
des besoins complémentaires au niveau de
l'entreprise et pour cela l'employeur va
pouvoir former que ce soit en interne
par le biais du tutorat ou en externe si
un organisme de formation qui peut
apporter une réponse à ce besoin de
connaissances complémentaires
en quoi l'approché par compétences où on
appelle ça aussi le recrutement par
compétence est elle une solution pour
les pme et tpe qui ont des difficultés
qu'ils sont pas comme les grands groupes
qui possèdent des drh
en quoi cette solution et est utile il
peut être utilisé par les pme et tpe
alors par rapport aux tpe pme
marc déjà ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'il ya une offre de service qui est
assez riche et varié on essaye de
répondre
nous essayons de répondre à l'ensemble
des besoins des tpe pme sur sur le
territoire ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que si l'employeur a plutôt une envie
d'autonomie dans son recrutement
il peut gérer de bout en bout son
opération de recrutement et il peut
s'appuyer sur son espace employeurs sur
pole emploi.fr
sur cet espace il va trouver un certain
nombre d'outils un certain nombre de
services donc simplifié enrichi et qui
peuvent répondre à ces besoins par
rapport à ses besoins
il peut déposer une offre d'emploi il
peut consulter la banque de profil il
peut avoir des conseils des aides au
recrutement préparer et conduire analysé
les entretiens il peut également
augmenter sa visibilité sur le site pole
emploi.fr en mettant sa marque
entreprises ce qui permet aux tpe pme
d'avoir un référencement et de pouvoir
ressortir avec l'ensemble des
informations il va l'enrichir
j'allais dire qu'il allait augmenter et
développer la communication par rapport
à son entreprise
quand on voit les employeurs qui sont là
ils peuvent effectivement faire appel à
cette visibilité sur le site pole
emploi.fr des sujets vous avez abordé
notamment le 13 décembre 2018 c'est un
événement que vous avez organisé avec
saint quentin en yvelines au ski tube
une matinée consacrée à l' approche par
compétences et vous l'on voit on va le
voir à l'image 1 il ya des
professionnels du recrutement
d'entreprises des représentants
d'entreprises du territoire qui était
venu écouter vos conseils
pôle emploi vous collaborez beaucoup
avec 51 en yvelines et notamment la
mission locale c'qui 16-25 qui s'est
saisie de cette approche on va écouter à
ce sujet les explications de son
président antoine le gall qui est aussi
conseiller communautaire à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle
on a sources et les jeunes par rapport à
un certain nombre de compétences et ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on leur
demande
eux-mêmes d'écrire leur propre
compétence et d'écrire aussi en une
phrase à quoi il ressemble quand même et
là on se voit que on se rend compte par
don qu'ils se posent d'énormes questions
sur la propre compétence et est-ce que
d'être ponctuelle c'est d'une compétence
par exemple voiliers et en fait on est
toujours dans la proche entre le savoir
être et la propre compétence en tant que
tel pour un emploi alors là on voit que
on change de côté finalement on est plus
du côté de l'employeur on est du côté du
demandeur d'emploi quels conseils vous
donner en tant que pôle emploi aux
demandeurs d'emploi pour rentrer dans
cette approche
je dirais valoriser vos compétences
l'ensemble de vos compétences que ce
soit vos savoirs aux savoir faire ou vos
savoirs être toutes les compétences
qu'elles soient professionnels ou extra
professionnelles sont des compétences
qui sont transférables quel que soit le
métier donc ce qui permet de se
positionner sur
certain nombre de postes ce qui vous
permet également de réaliser votre carte
de visite de pouvoir être visible auprès
des employeurs de pouvoir promouvoir
votre profil auprès des entreprises qui
vont avoir derrière une approche
compétences qui sera différente
il faut savoir que au niveau des postes
actuels on ne sera pas uniquement sur un
cv mais on sera également sur cette
compétence recherchée attendu et sur
lesquels nous accompagnons les
compétences nous les accompagnons en
mettant en place des actions
d'adaptation au poste de travail
nous sommes conscients que lorsqu'il y a
des difficultés de recrutement pour les
tpe pme
bien entendu il y à un sourcing et c'est
ce que disait monsieur erwan le gall qui
réalisait avec un potentiel de candidats
sur le marché du travail
mais après qu'est ce qui se passe
lorsque dans ce marché du travail on ne
retrouve pas les candidats nécessaire
mais il faut à ce moment-là élargir le
sourcing et être sur la proche
compétences on commence d'abord par les
demandeurs d'emploi puisqu'il faut
alimenter le sourcing et en même temps
on fait la promotion auprès des
employeurs et nous les accompagnons dans
cette démarche de recrutement
alors on arrive bientôt au terme de ce
magazine on va faire un petit
récapitulatif avec cette infographie
l'approchent par compétences si on doit
la résumer à alors elle permet d'abord
de s'appuyer en priorité sur le savoir
faire du candidat ou du côté de
l'employeur s'est il s'appuie sur le
savoir faire du candidat pour chercher
le bon profil c'est à dire les
compétences acquises lors de ses
expériences professionnelles antérieures
et qui peuvent être utiles ou
transférables dans le nouvel emploi pour
lequel y postule et le deuxième critère
on l'a dit c'est le savoir est c'est par
exemple l'état toutes les attitudes que
vous devez adopter dans un cadre
professionnel et que vous pouvez
valorisé comme la ponctualité l'esprit
des clips ou encore la rigueur
zohra douchy merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur notre plateau et on va terminer avec
deux agendas à noter le ski club
organise le mercredi 30 janvier de 8h30
à 12h30 une conférence sur
l'optimisation des cvthèques savoir
organiser sa collecte de cv dans le
cadre de vos recrutements pour gagner du
temps
frictions obligatoire sur le site sky
entreprise.com autre rendez vous le
mercredi 23 janvier la mission locale ce
qui est 16-25 organise une visite de la
maison de retraite korian à maurepas
objectif faire découvrir différents
métiers comme aide-soignant ou
assistants de soins hospitaliers
pour y participer vous devez vous
inscrire auprès de la mission locale
avant le 18 janvier d'autres visites et
sessions seront programmées durant
l'inde et durant l'année pardon plus
d'informations sur le site internet de
la mission locale ou sur le compte
twitter de skyway 16 25
merci nous avoir suivis c'est la fin de
cette émission rendez vous le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro de mode
d'emploi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]